[Music]
and II apparently has been working on a
new comedy bit for the last couple of
weeks I don't know what it is Andy says
he wants to try it out tonight you ready
Andy yeah thanks Conan uh I'm ready are
you ready Allen okay
great Andy we're all set go ahead with
your comedy bit member this remember
this remember this remember this have
any any any Andy what stop why that's
not a comedy piece all you're doing is
saying a member this and then showing
pictures of stuff well yeah that's how
it start but it changes I mean there's
more to it
all right fine go ahead stop it stop it
I don't know Andy again you just changed
member this to member him yeah it's a
trip down memory lane they're loving it
right
oh for God's sakes anybody can do that
Alan give me a screen okay all right
remember this
remember this
remember this then remember this
remember oh my god remember this okay Oh
God
take that down Alan those were awful yes
not so easy is it
that's not fair I'm trying to do a
comedy show and now the crowd is upset
Conan I think I can get him back
remember this
[Applause]
whoa you shut me out of context that
seems real obscene
you're right I didn't mean it that way
at all I know I blame them they're
they're like it's snow and now that's
awful looking it's well it's impressive
but it's awful